I took my younger cousin to Italy for
his birthday and uh that's awesome we're
meeting my ex-girlfriend out there so
when we planned this trip she was my
girlfriend but by the time the trip came
around she was my
ex and they're flirting with each other
they're being like all weird and I
started getting jealous they end up
ditching me so I find them later on and
they're smooching
oh when I was trying to get him to see
things from my point of view it just
like we had completely different stories
of the event here's the thing he's 21 or
22 yeah everyone who's 21 to 24 is a
sociopath there's a rare occasion that
the person at that age can think outside
of themselves they can they're ahead of
the curve you also got to give them time
and forgiveness is a two-way street
sounds like you've lowered your end of
the bridge he's got to lower his end so
you can both cross m